[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci d'être là et que je
vais pas vous faire des massages
pourquoi pas après tout je m'appelle ses
fans c'est effectivement marqué derrière
je vais effectivement essayé de vous
proposer de faire un petit tour à la
plage tous ensemble alors avant d'aller
à la plage je vais peut-être vous
expliquer pourquoi je pense que c'est
une bonne idée
donc il ya mon métier d'abord et puis
mes passions je suis le directeur d'une
organisation non gouvernementale d'une
ong de protection de l'océan des vagues
du littoral et des plages elle s'appelle
surf rider foundation
mais avant de rentrer dans se balade à
la plage je pense qu'il faut que je vous
explique pourquoi j'ai fait ce choix là
et c'est aussi lié à mon passé et mon
passé aussi professionnelle et de coeur
avant d'être dans une ong de protection
de l'environnement j'ai passé de très
nombreuses années dans une organisation
non gouvernementale d'urgence et
d'humanitaires et j'ai couru la planète
après les catastrophes naturelles et
dans les zones de guerre alors que ce
soit en allemagne pour des inondations
que ça soit au salvador pour des
tremblements de terre que ça soit au
venezuela pour encore d'autres
inondations rendent à pour des volcans
et des éruptions je vous en passe et des
plus serrés mais ça m'a profondément
marqué et cette question de la manière
dont l'être humain dans une situation
exceptionnelle est capable de mobiliser
des ressources incroyables de vivre
ensemble était quelque chose qui m'a
vraiment profondément marqué dans en
tant que personne et en tant que
professionnel dont le métier que je fais
aujourd'hui et puis je l'évoqué tout à
l'heure j'ai aussi été en zone de guerre
voilà ça c'est l'afghanistan kosovo puis
ça c'est l'irak irak était ma dernière
mission
alors la zone de guerre c'est
particulier parce que on est
heureusement de moins en moins nombreux
à aller à la guerre même si c'est une de
mes grandes peurs un jour que ces choses
ressurgissent on y viendra les questions
de conflits sont importantes mais c'est
c'est vraiment en zone de guerre qu'on
voit le maximum du nom vivre ensemble de
l'oubli du vivre ensemble et de la
négation du grand sable c'est d'autant
plus fou que dans la majorité de ces
pays les gens qui n'arrivent plus à
vivre ensemble sont des gens qui
auraient dû encore plus que les autres
enfants alors je vous ai un peu plombé
l'ambiance
je vous ai déjà pas fait les massages
donc je vais au moins essayer de
repartir sur notre propos initial parce
que quand je revenais de ses missions
systématiquement il ya un endroit où
j'allais me ressourcer ou jallet méditer
un peu ce que j'avais vu
c'est la plage alors je les propose un
tour à la plage on va le faire quand
même ce tour à la plage qui n'aiment pas
la plage ici à y en a toujours
yann ariane pas le chocolat aime pas et
frites ils sont rares mais à toujours
vous ne vous aime pas la plage on va pas
leur demander pourquoi je vais
considérer que les autres mais la plage
et quelque part dans le monde dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui ça me rassure
de voir qu'on est capable d'être
nombreux pardon pour ceux qui n'aiment
pas et tous ensemble à se réunir autour
de ce qu on n est pas autour de ce qui
nous fait peur petit message donc la
plage c'est une image d'épinal une image
d'épinal là on y est complètement une
image d'epinal pour la minute
géographique je vous demande de
pardonner mon rapprochement des vosges
avec le littoral pour la minute
culturelle une image d'épinal c'est une
estampe populaire aux couleurs vives
alors couleurs vives populaire ben moi
j'y vois la plage couleurs vives la
plage c'est vous l'avez devant c'est le
bleu c'est les bleus c'est le ciel qui
rencontre la mère c'est pour vous qui
êtes à paris et dans toutes les villes
c'est le bonheur de n'avoir aucun
obstacle à la vue de voir l'infini de
l'azur donc c'est le bleu et puis c'est
aussi si ça passe voilà c'est aussi le
jeune le doré le soleil le sable la
plage c'est c'est ce plaisir de mélanger
les couleurs de les vivre et d'être
imprégné de ses couleurs alors cette
balade à la plage cette balade dans les
couleurs c'est un petit peu ma
proposition aujourd'hui puisque donc je
lui ai dit on est dans l'image d'epinal
on est dans les couleurs et dans le
populaire mais le populaire il prend
totalement son sens à la plage parce que
d'abord owni fréquentes plein d'autres
gens là vous avez les meilleurs peintres
de la plage ce qui contrairement nous
arrive à faire le bleu et le jaune dans
la même journée réservée dans le ciel
dans la mer et sur le sable on est un
petit peu limité mais vous avez autre
chose est-ce que vous sauvez du dernier
15 août que vous avez passé à la plage
le populaire c'est qu'à la plage qui est
un grand lieu de nature de temps en
temps on se retrouve vraiment vraiment
vraiment nombreux à vivre ensemble
alors on est tous là dans un moment un
peu particulier à la plage le 15 août
c'est très très spécial c'est rare dans
une vie d'être tous cas c'est comme ça
les uns avec les autres dans un
mouvement somme toute agréable
vous avez à nouveau un peu l'habitude il
ya le métro les spectacles mais ce n'est
pas pareil la plage la plage est en
maillot on est presque nue on est sans
artifice et pourtant on est là tous
ensemble tous ensemble en fait pas
complètement il ya un petit peu deux
catégories de gens à la plage ça se voit
d'abord dans la répartition géographique
quand on veut aller se baigner
il ya des gens qui sont autorisés à
l'est entre les drapeaux de baignade
près drapeaux bleus c'est les plagistes
et où ils ont qu une envie toute la
journée c'est de rester allongé le plus
longtemps possible
il ya une deuxième catégorie de gens un
peu plus énervé où ils n'ont qu'une
envie c'est de se lever toute la journée
veulent se lever sur une planche et
descendre des vagues
c'est leur faire alors les surfers c'est
une j'en suis un jeu s'obligeait le dire
parce que je vais dire des choses
voudrait pas être accusée de d'être
partie prenante en tout cas je tiens à
dire que parti pris en tout cas parce
que je suis parti preuve les surfers
c'est ce sont des grands malades
le surfeur c'est un malade et il ya des
symptômes à cette maladie et les
symptômes physiques donc normalement on
avait fait un peu plus blond parce
qu'ils se décolore avec le sel on a le
teint un peu plus à l'est parce qu'on
passe son temps dans l'eau et puis il ya
des symptômes plus particuliers + plus
difficile à gérer
on a du sable partout dans mais dans sa
voiture dans son lit dans sa maison on
en a toujours
et puis il ya un dernier je vous dis
c'est un secret que nous ne le sait pas
surfer ils ont toujours une drôle
d'odeur parce que l'hiver ils font pipi
dans leurs combinaisons
il faut pas le dire mais les symptômes
physiques à des problèmes de rétention
c'est compliqué quand on est enceinte
et puis allez sa robe sicot logique le
surfeur est un obsessionnel des prêts à
laisser ses amis sa famille tout le
temps son espèce de quête de vagues il a
quand même du mal est toujours en banque
et c'est un obsessionnel mais il a
quelque chose de particulier le surfeur
c'est qu'il est tout le temps à courir
d'ailleurs est en avance sur son temps
par l'état cède en avance sur la vague
mais le surfeur est en avance sur son
temps et pour parler des plages je
voudrais vous parler des surfers parce
que les surfeurs sont parmi les gens qui
fréquentent le plus les plages il les
fréquente et ça leur donne une
particularité c'est qu'ils sont en
avance sur notre société
si j'osais je dirais qu'ils sont avant
gardiste on n'en parle pas souvent comme
ça les surfers ont un regard sur la
société qui leur donne parfois un coup
d'avancé alors des fois un peu d'avancé
sur de jolies choses et des fois un coup
d'avancé sur des choses moins jolie dans
les années 70 les surfers déjà
en préalable une société qui va toujours
monté en ce sens pourtant partagent une
communauté de valeurs de passion mais
invente le daoui hawaï les invente le
localisme qui est une manière cool
d'être raciste l'idée c'est de dire ça
c'est ma vague j'ai pas envie de la
partager avec toi tu vas de la plage d'à
côté si t'es pas content je te bastonne
donc c'est les serveurs bon c'est le
côté pas cool ça date des années 70 ils
ont peut-être déjà un coup d'avancé une
époque quand même plutôt de
communautarisme de van volkswagen et de
peace and love buzz avant de sawai mais
invente des belles choses des surfeurs
dans les années 80 ils lancent l'alerté
disent les océans aujourd'hui sont
pollués comme jamais ils l'ont été et il
crée même des organisations comme celle
pour laquelle je travaille pour réagir
dans les années 90 il attire l'attention
sur déjà les excès de la société de
consommation
les déchets sont partout sur les plages
le jetable consommables usage unique
dans les années 2000 ils reprennent un
coup d'avancé sur la société là ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux ils retournent
dans le localisme et ils sont à nouveau
dans le rejet de l'autre
donc ces surfeurs sont des avant
gardistes peut-être qu'ils ont des
choses à nous dire puisque ce sont des
avant gardistes à pourquoi ils ont des
choses à nu liens parce que ce sont des
urbains qui sont très souvent à la
nature c'est de plus en plus rare
aujourd'hui
et eux ce sont des lanceurs d'alerté
mais pas ils n'ont pas observé quelques
choisis l'ont vécue ils sont baignés
dans l'océan ils sont baignés dans la
plage ils sont couverts de sable
ce sont de véritables rats de
laboratoire ce sont des lanceurs
dallaire donc ça vaut peut-être la peine
qu'on les aime qu'on les écoute et
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'ils nous disent
ces surfers
il nous parle de réchauffement
climatique ils y sont ils sont en plein
dedans ils sont dans l'océan l'océan est
un acteur clé de la régulation du climat
mais aussi c'est une victime du
dérèglement climatique
les surfeurs ils le voient ils sont dans
l'eau la température se modifie le
savent pas ce qu'ils doivent ajuster
leurs combinaisons en fonction de la
température
et ce alors qu'ils sont dans les îles y
voit le corail qui meurent parce que
l'océan celle ci dit fille et l'océan
qui sa fille qui s'acidifient c'est
autant de capacités de régulation du
climat en moins parce que le sien est un
poumon de la planète les surfeurs ils
sont aussi excusez moi je regarde ils
sont aussi victimes
ils ne peuvent plus aller à l'eau en
méditerranée les surfeurs et des
t-shirts jaunes là qu'ils vivent à nice
peuvent plus aller à l'eau il ya des
espèces invasives ya des algues
dangereuse pour l'homme et il n'arrive
pas à y aller et puis je vous montrer la
photo les surfeurs il adore les vagues
qu'est ce qui crée les vagues les
tempêtes et surfer ils ont bien
remarquez que les modifications
climatiques sont des modifications
quotidienne de l'augmentation des
tempêtes à l'oreille serveur qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils voient les tempêtes il
voit la marée qui monte mais ils ont
déjà compris qu'il va y avoir une
conséquence sur ses plages où vous
propose que l'aïe se balader la plage de
votre enfance vous avez peut-être déjà
remarqué qu'elle a commencé à changer
vous allez peut-être de plus vous êtes
petit qu'on ait vu la plage images
d'epinal tout à l'heure des maldives où
la plage de l'océan atlantique où une
plage de méditerranée vous avez sans
doute déjà remarqué qu'elle a commencé à
changer parce que le climat change parce
que les tempêtes se sont multipliées par
ce que l'eau monte
vous avez des photos on a commencé et
c'est d'intervenir sur le sable parce
qu'il faut créer des barrières
naturelles
et puis l'homme dans son fantasme du
tout contrôle il a commencé à mettre des
machines il essaye de travailler sur les
plages il veut c'est d'actualité
aujourd'hui érigé des murs ériger des
murs contre les migrants contre les
immigrés entre l'océan il croit qu'il va
arriver à arrêter le mouvement naturel
qui ne peut pas s'arrêter comme ça donc
il fait des murs voilà il fait des murs
il dit tiens et si je faisais des murs
pourtant il faut reculer un nom il
faudra accepter d'arrêter cette machine
folle et les surfeurs ça ils le voient
les serveurs il s'en aperçoivent sur fin
ils se disent qu'on peut pas continuer à
vivre ensemble tous comme ça alors par
rapport à ça je voudrais vous proposer
deux choses la plage que je vous montre
maintenant une plage d'aujourd'hui mais
qui a déjà commencé à changer je vais
demander elle proposait tout à l'heure
un label de fermer les yeux
je vous demandais de l'imaginer demain
quand on va devoir s'être organisés pour
faire face aux défis du chef du
changement climatique la plage vous avez
là c'est déjà une plage où il ya de
nombreux usages vous voyez un parking
peut imaginer des commerces du tourisme
on voit un petit un petit parc
d'attractions on voit évidemment l'océan
avec tout ce qui peut y avoir de pêche
de surf de ballades d'imaginer qu'à tout
ça on va rajouter les murs on va
rajouter le béton mais on va aussi
construire des énergies renouvelables
parce qu'on n'a pas le choix il faut
utiliser tout ce qu'on peut pour mettre
de l'énergie renouvelable
il ya du vent il ya du soleil il ya des
puissances de marée et de vents galaade
dans l'océan donc on va aménager tout ça
mais le problème c'est que les plages en
même temps se réduisent l'océan va
monter l'eau c'est un de plus en plus
polluée donc on va vouloir mettre
toujours plus de choses sur toujours
moins d espace avec de plus en plus de
monde ça s'appelle les conflits d'usagé
et c'est pas joli pour le vivre ensemble
donc je vous montre une autre plage ça
c'est une belle métaphore d'aujourd'hui
à gauche
vous avez lu mein toujours plus nombreux
qui doit construire pour vivre pour
vivre qui prend de la place
à droite vous avez l'océan et l'océan
lui die monde parce que l'humain la
dérégler et parce qu à dérégler le
climat
donc cet océan va monter cet humain il
est de l'autre côté et il ya une zone au
milieu tampon qu'est la plage cette zone
merveilleuse c'est peut-être d'ici 10 20
ans la fin de ma plage de rêve
systématique en tout cas sans béton de
nature où on peut se retrouver
certes rarement mais tous ensemble
nombreux puis parfois tout seul et c'est
peut-être la fin de ses plages de rêve
un jour mais dans la société
d'aujourd'hui va falloir accepter qu'on
va perdre des choses et qu'on va en
gagner
alors moi j'ai un rêve de plage si c'est
la fin de la plage de rêve et ce rêve de
plage
je serai le partager avec vous ce rêve
de plage c'est que sur ses plages qui
préfigure la société de demain de la
raréfaction des ressources ici le
territoire mais dans le monde entier
l'eau la nourriture le pétrole quand on
va devoir faire face aux tensions aux
conflits d'usagé mon rêve c'est qu'on
arrive à avoir inventé sur les plages en
douceur en harmonie une manière de gérer
ça gentiment tendrement tous ensemble
qu'on arrive à partager
et ce rêve il commence aussi par l'idée
que on partage des choses qui sont
immatérielles alors je vais une nouvelle
fois vous proposer une balade avec moi
je vais vous proposer quand vous
quitterez cette salle car vous allez
rentrer au bureau ou à la maison ou la
prochaine fois que vous êtes sur une
plage au moment d'un coucher de soleil
privilégié en tenant par la main ce que
vous m
ce que vous aimez celui ou celle que
vous aimez en regardant les derniers
rayons du soleil se couchait dans la mer
et avec les mouettes qui s'en vont je
vais vous demander à ce moment-là de
réfléchir à ce qui est essentiel ce qui
est nécessaire et ce qui est souhaitable
pour la question des plages et du climat
ce qui est essentiel c'est le
développement des énergies renouvelables
ce qui est nécessaire c'est qu'il faut
continuer à pêcher à nourrir la planète
et ce qui est souhaitable c'est qu'on
continue à pouvoir profiter de ces
moments privilégiés de loisirs savoir ce
qui est essentiel nécessaire ou
souhaitable c'est dans nos coeurs a tous
je vais vous proposer des réfléchir la
prochaine fois vous voyez un coucher de
soleil avec en vous souvenant de ce
moment et en vous disant le vivre
ensemble ils commencent par être capable
à un moment donné de rêver de savoir
dans une zone de paix comme la plage
entre l'océan et les humains cette zone
de paix entre le
coeur et la tête qu'est ce qui est
vraiment indispensable pour nous tous et
quand on l'aura trouvé on sera mieux
armé pour le partager avec les autres et
vivre ensemble en harmonie c'est ma
proposition et je vous remercie de
m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]